une période sans cinéma pour certains
habitués du grand écran depuis mercredi
21 juillet l'instauration du passani
terre les contrôles sont obligatoires
avant d'acheter son ticket
l'interdiction d'autant plus frustrante
que lorsqu'elle vient d'une erreur
j'étais la semaine dernière mais
aujourd'hui je ne peux pas pourquoi
et bien parce que il faut la preuve que
que j'étais vacciner deux fois alors je
ne peux pas être vaccinés deux fois
parce que j'ai eu la coved et là où j'ai
été vacciné il me se sont trompés ils
ont ils ont vu que je devais passer la
deuxième piqûre et je n'ai pas à la
passe et voilà alors maintenant je suis
bloqué des mesures qui peuvent aussi
être source de colère comme pour cette
dame qui ne veut pas se faire vacciner
j'estime que ça c'est une dictature
c'est à dire voilà on ne peut plus aller
au cinéma parce qu'on n'a pas de passe
et si on veut aller au cinéma au
restaurant tout ça et bien il va falloir
se faire vacciner de force pour les
cinémas ce sont des contraintes en plus
pour recevoir les visiteurs
c'est pas évident on perd du temps le
dirait un certain nombre de personnes
mais je dois quand même dire qu'ils sont
très minoritaires qui sont pas très
content évidemment de devoir présenter
leurs passes certains ne l'ont pas donc
on est obligé de refouler aussi
certaines personnes c'est assez rare ça
se passe plutôt bien dans l'ensemble et
on espère que ça va durer le moins
longtemps possible
les répercussions se constate
directement sur la fréquentation qui a
baissé de 70%
parce que je peux employer le mot
catastrophique c'est peut-être un petit
peu trop fort mais enfin c'est quand
même très difficile surtout depuis
mercredi c'était déjà pas facile avant
il faut le dire contrairement à ce qu'on
entend ici ou là surtout spécialement
moi j'ai remarqué c'est en tout cas sur
les blockbusters les gros films à très
fort potentiel
là on a vraiment une chute de
fréquentation très importante quand même
et qui s'est très très nettement
amplifié depuis mercredi dernier
seule lumière au bout du tunnel pour le
directeur l'espoir d'une future immunité
collective
elle permettrait d'éviter une quatrième
vague à la fin de l'été et pouvoir
appréhender au mieux les périodes de
forte affluence pour les cinémas dès
l'automne
pendant tout le cinéma